not all Republicans are on the same page
as President Trump when it comes to
tariffs and to what he said on gun
control in that meeting Nebraska senator
Ben Sasse has some serious problems
about what the president has been saying
he joins us live tonight senator thanks
for being here good to be here let's
start about steel on aluminum you have a
real problem with what the president
announced today why trade is great for
America trade is great for American
families and no trade war has ever
worked we don't want to make America
1930 again
and the Forgotten men and women of
America don't want to be drafted into a
trade war it doesn't work trade creates
jobs and all the data shows that and
trade lowers prices for American
families trade wars do the opposite your
statement was read to Sarah Sanders
today here's what she said and then
listen to the trade representative light
Heiser I don't know that the president
will or should ever apologize for
protecting American workers and
certainly not two senators as the
president ran on this he feels strongly
about it when I talk to a miss workers
ranchers farmers that's it it's wages
and it's jobs the president's objective
is we have to get more jobs back to
America we have to reduce the deficit
and that will ultimately put pressure on
wages so do you believe that there are
countries that are dumping steel into
the u.s. there are and there are extant
laws that we should use for dispute
resolution but here's what happens if
you start down a trade warpath like you
said in the last segment if you own a
steel mill today was great for you if
you consume steel and every American
family at the store tonight bought
something that has different metals in
it today is a bad day for you and that's
just the first day when the trade war
gets worse it means there's going to be
retaliatory tariffs against the farmers
and ranchers of America and the
producers and the workers of America
we're going to lose as consumers and
produce just to explain it to people at
home there are countries who charge more
for steel at home and then put their
steel in the US at a lower price which
then burdens those companies and if you
talk to the the states where they saw
many many jobs leave a lot of those
states Donald Trump won by 55 60 65
percent so they're saying why not
repatriate the American supply chain and
do it
all here yes so what what trade has done
over the last many decades it is driven
down prices for American consumers and
it's created jobs there are all sorts of
challenges with what China does but what
that requires is that we engage more in
asia-pacific not pull back
there's nothing China once more this
president's already said and he ran on
this that he wasn't gonna be in the TPP
that he was an e ran around the country
on this platform and the country elected
him so for the people who say why
doesn't that matter how do you respond
yes so this has leftist economic policy
and we've tried it a whole bunch of
times over the last two centuries and
every time American families have
suffered it's bad policy I get that the
president ran on a bunch of this but
there are a whole bunch of issues where
once he got into the White House he
started listening to advisors and he got
to positions that are better for the
country in the long term his regulatory
reform agenda has been great this trade
policy will be disastrous
okay the other thing that you have a big
concern about is what he said about guns
and basically due process he since the
White House has since walked back that
and said you know he wasn't talking
about affecting the Second Amendment but
you kind of jumped on that and put out a
statement about what he said in that
meeting yes so here's what America means
it means that we believe that rights
come to us from God V in nature and
government exists to secure and protect
our rights government doesn't give us
rights and when you say something like
we'll take the guns first we'll grab the
guns first and later we'll have a due
process conversation what that means is
government is first and hopefully you
have a bureaucrat that you trust to
decide what rights you have that's not
how America works so American citizens
have the whole Bill of Rights available
to them and then in the cases of people
who are deranged or have committed
crimes then we do due process and we
take away certain privileges that they
have do you think that this that there
is a possibility of getting something on
school safety and guns out of this
Congress I think yesterday you saw David
French issue a proposal that the White
House was paying some attention to it
didn't get a lot of play in yesterday's
kind of reality TV governance meeting
that they did but David French was
talking about gun viral violence
restraining orders and I think there's
some interest and things like that in
the cases of people who have mental
problems we should obviously do
something to make sure that they can't
get access to weapons that that needs to
happen via due process not through some
bureaucrat who gets to pre-ordained who
gets what First Amendment and Second
Amendment rights understanding that you
don't like what he said at that meeting
there were a lot of people who looked at
the meeting on immigration and the
meeting on gun control and said hey
listen it's open he's got Democrats he's
got Republicans they're throwing out
ideas why is that so bad to be talked
about in a in kind of a negative light
as reality TV
well transparency is great but you don't
try to rewrite the Constitution shooting
from the hip and I think that's what you
saw yesterday when you saw Dianne
Feinstein from California giddy as a
three-year-old kid ecstatic about the
idea that there gonna be a whole bunch
of new gun bans coming into America you
know that's not gonna happen right
senator I mean they're you're they're up
on Capitol Hill to prevent that from
happening and this president is not
gonna push that is he do you truly
believe that I'm excited about the fact
that the White House which has the
biggest megaphone in the world today set
a bunch of more truly American things
about the Bill of Rights and what rights
American citizens have yesterday in that
meeting the tape is the tape and if you
say you're gonna grab guns first and
worry about due process later that's not
something that you give your listeners
and viewers a lot of comfort your
characterized as one of the Republican
senators who's most critical of this
president you sent a flake senator
corker fair I don't think so you know
punditry loves to jump on every issue
and say are you Pro Trump or anti Trump
or your mega or yeah principle by
principle let's go down the list of what
many people says are his accomplishments
tax reform signed into law I voted for
Neil Gorsuch wonderful and let's go
broader than that I ran on the Judiciary
Committee to fight for his judges
because he's nominated a whole bunch of
great movies who were judges ever
confirmed in the first year chuck
Grassley the chairman of our committee
from Iowa has led a really great process
and we set the all-time record last year
granting the permit for the Keystone
pipeline along with other energy moves
increasing energy regulatory reform by
this president has been really strong
860 Obama regulations pulled or
suspended u.s. embassy from Tel Aviv to
Jerusalem supported military crackdown
on Isis largely seen as force
to retreat from Iraq and Syria in big
port a lot of progress withdrawal from
the Paris climate agreement yep
enforce the red line in Syria yep
there's a Wall Street Journal op-ed that
says the only good thing about Donald
Trump is all his policies fair to say
that there are a lot of things that this
president has done that you are
definitely supportive of but how he
talks about that or his communication of
it and how he comports himself you have
a problem no that's not my problem so
I'm I'm the second most conservative
senator by voting record and I'm one
only five people in the US Senate that's
never been a politician before we need a
lot of disruption to this system the
city doesn't work and so one of the
great things about the president is it
gives us an opportunity to relook at a
whole bunch of business as usual things
that Washington's been doing that don't
work at a policy level I support the
vast majority of what he's done again
judges chief among them but at the level
of basic civics we have a crisis in this
country that the next generation doesn't
understand the American idea 41% of
Americans under age 35 tell pollsters
they think the First Amendment is
dangerous on the left you got a whole
bunch of people who are disinterested in
religious liberty polling now tells us
that on the right you got a whole bunch
of people that are disinterested in
freedom of the press well those freedoms
the five freedoms of the First Amendment
religion press speech assembly protest
they're all bundled up as one thing we
haven't taught civics in this country
for 40 or 50 years and right now we're
not doing a better job of that when you
say things on from the national bully
pulpit of we'll grab the guns first and
we'll deal with due process later that
didn't help them solve our civics
problem so my concerns are primarily
about passing on the American idea of a
Free Republic to the next generation at
the level of policy there's a whole
bunch of stuff I'm doing behind the
scenes to help this administration and I
applaud a lot of it senator we
appreciate your time as always thanks
for having me